let's talk about Donald Trump's
commandeering of American television to
propagandize about the border wall over
which he shut down the government last
night
we will talk about the content of this
address I mentioned yesterday during a
live stream that I did covering this and
and also earlier on yesterday's show
that there are really kind of three
issues here number one is is there
actually an undocumented immigration
crisis I laid out the case yesterday for
why there is not secondly if there were
such an immigration crisis would the
wall that Donald Trump is proposing be
the solution to that crisis I explained
why it would not and then issue number
three layer number three was would a
presidential address of this type in
primetime on television
be the right place for overt political
lobbying for the policy that Donald
Trump wants and I also made the case
that it was not and the LA the the
speech in the end was nine minutes long
half just lies at a rate that we maybe
have not seen previously during a Trump
speech the other half just anecdotal
appeals to emotion and I'm not gonna
focus too too much on those because I
think our audience mostly understands
that you don't make policy based on
anecdotal appeals to emotion but we
should talk about the lies that we're
told because that actually is important
but the primary takeaway is this address
never should have happened it was purely
political it was a lobbying speech I
actually would be okay with a
presidential address in primetime on all
TV networks for lobbying the public
about a real emergency or a crisis right
we have a climate change emergency on
our planet if we had a president say I'm
going to address the American people
because of the crisis that is climate
change in what we're doing to our planet
that would actually make sense because
it's real a real crisis could be we've
got a president who's an accused serial
sex assault er with at least one child
accuser that is more of a crisis than
the crisis of undocumented immigrants
coming over the us-mexico border so
there are many ways in which I would
support a president saying I need to
address the nation tonight
this is not one of them and most of the
lies that Trump told were told up front
I'll go through a few of them I'm not
gonna play the nine minute thing because
it's only nine minutes and it's very
easy to find I'll focus just on
analyzing the lies that we're told
Donald Trump called this he sort of
opened this thing yesterday calling it a
growing crisis and as I've already
outlined it's not a crisis at all but
it's definitely not growing there's no
evidence that this is a growing problem
border crossings are lower and lower and
lower each year dating all the way back
to the year 2000 there has been an
increase in the last few months but
that's mostly asylum seekers who are
people going through the correct legal
process to ask for asylum in the United
States Donald Trump said we don't have
any way of returning people to where
they came from quickly quickly is
subjective but we do have a mechanism
for doing that however the fact that
Trump has shut down government is
actually what's slowing that process
down making it so that immigration
hearings have slowed down to an absolute
halt Trump arguing that we are really
hurt economically that this is a strain
on resources undocumented immigrants
that does not appear to be true
undocumented immigrants pay in to social
welfare programs from which they will
never get money back out they are
single-handedly holding on their backs
and shoulders multiple industries which
would collapse without them and most
importantly Donald Trump made the case
that economically undocumented
immigration is hurting the United States
because undocumented immigrants drive
wages down what is an amazing ruse about
that is that it's the corporation's
who want to pay lower wages that are the
ones benefiting from that and it's an
unbelievably a brazen act of misplaced
ire to be mad at the people coming here
to work for a better life than the
corporations that take advantage of them
and choose to hire undocumented
immigrants without being punished if we
started enforcing penalties on
corporations that hire undocumented
immigrants
you would solve an overwhelming majority
of the problem if corporations weren't
known to hire undocumented immigrants
then you wouldn't have so many people
getting jobs and looking for jobs it
would be a problem that in great part
would fix itself then Trump talked about
Americans are dying from drugs that are
coming over the us-mexico border listen
that that is it's true that Americans
are dying from drugs but that's not
coming exclusively because of drugs
coming over the us-mexico border a lot
of it is marijuana first of all which
nobody is dying from and secondly
according to the DEA it's mostly being
smuggled through ports of entry not
through the parts of the border which
would be blocked with Trump's border
wall ok understand that most of the
drugs coming into the United States from
Mexico are coming hidden and smuggled in
vehicles and on persons through the
actual legitimate on-the-record ports of
entry meaning a wall wouldn't do
anything about it Donald Trump is saying
that thousands of Americans are being
killed by undocumented immigrants yearly
I was not able to find data that
supports that although I'm open to
having my mind changed Trump insisting
that it's a humanitarian crisis well
just saying that doesn't actually make
it so and then Trump starting to move
into the appeal to emotion phase of his
address by saying women and children are
the biggest victims of undocumented
immigration that is true but women and
children are always the biggest victims
period all over the world from all sorts
of circumstances that doesn't justify a
wall between the u.s. and Mexico and it
doesn't prove that we have an
undocumented immigration crisis Donald
Trump deliberately conflated border
security and a 25 billion dollar wall or
35 billion dollar wall by the time it's
all said and done and what's really
important to understand there is that
it's untrue what Trump said that
Democrats aren't willing to fund border
security Democrats have actually been
willing to provide border security
funding not for the wall but for
technology and
Staffing in exchange for reopening
government and it's Mitch McConnell and
Donald Trump who have refused to give
any of those bills any serious
consideration it is untrue also that
everybody wanted a wall until Trump was
president and all of a sudden they don't
just because as a Democrat you might
have been willing years ago to give
Republicans some border fencing a few
miles of it in exchange for things you
wanted doesn't mean you're a hypocrite
because you now don't want a twenty five
thirty or thirty-five billion dollar
wall across the entire border so big
picture you have a government that is
not shut down because of Democrats Trump
shut it down you have a president who
has failed to get what he wants and is
now throwing a literal temper tantrum
which caused him to commandeer
television networks for nine minutes
plus the lead-up coverage and the Pelosi
Schumer follow-up speech and the
analysis of it for several hours across
multiple networks and most importantly
there is no crisis and at least for now
Pat there's no indication that this
address has really moved the needle for
Donald Trump
well we'll see I think this comes across
as effective propaganda honestly because
you have the president on his own turf
in the Oval Office delivering a speech
to the nation calling the immigration
situation of crisis calling it an
emergency I think that's going to be
effective about you know people just
tuning in to their local programming on
CBS or NBC wanting to watch their
favorite show they may not follow
politics that closely they may not stick
around and hear the fact checks here the
response is given by Pelosi closely and
Schumer and you know at this moment a
majority or at least a plurality of
Americans blame Trump for the shutdown I
would not be surprised if in the coming
days we see that that's flipped a little
bit those numbers may shift but you're
already starting to see even
conservative political analysts say it
looks like Trump is going to fail and
he's going to have to relent and allow
government to be reopened we will talk a
little bit more about that but in the
short term I don't see this helping
Donald Trump it came off is so not
credible it came off as so flaccid and
beta in every way
and it also may have been an illegal use
of government resources for Trump's
campaign because minutes before the
speech the reelect trump campaign sent
out an email asking for donations on the
basis of the immigration crisis and
previewing Trump's speech and if you
consider that sort of part of Trump's
campaign this was a political speech
used in this manner to help his campaign
and there are possible ways in that that
made have even violated campaign finance
law although I wouldn't expect him to be
held accountable for it we will follow
it and see what the impact is